قال وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل بن
فرحان ان اسرائيل تمارس سياسه ممنهجه
لتجويع قطاع غزه واكد بن فرحان في مؤتمر
صحفي مشترك مع نظيره المصري في القاهره
ضروره الزام اسرائيل بالقانون الدولي
الانساني والاسراع لوقف الحرب في
غزه القانون الدولي والقانون الانساني
الدولي له قيمه وله الزاميه للجميع وهذا
ينطبق على اسرائيل كما ينطبق على غيرهم
وهذا هو التحدي الكبير والذي تفضلت به
يجسد هذا رفض الجانب الاسرائيلي لحكم
المحكمه رفضا كاملا وعدم التجاوب معه هو
ما اتى
بالوضع الذي نحن فيها الان الذي نشاهد
نقترب من 3 ال مدني قتيل في
غزه السياسه ممنهجه للتجويع ول الحصار في
عقاب جماعي للشعب الفلسطيني في غزه
المطلوب هو الزام اسرائيل بما نلتزم به
كلنا وهو التقيد بالقانون الدولي والقانون
الس الدولي